[MUSIC PLAYING]
I've always been fascinated by
movie and TV show directors.
Frankly, shooting movies
seems like a lot of fun.
The idea that you're in
control of your camera,
framing each shot, and
creating an evocative scene
really inspires me.
I'm Ankur Kotwal, and
I'm going to show you
that as Maps Developers, we
have the same creative direction
over UI.
We get to build our map scenes
and create evocative user
experiences.
The Maps API provides a
very sophisticated camera
that enables you to frame
your maps in three dimensions.
It's got the capabilities you'd
expect, such as projection,
zooming, and panning.
But additionally, you can
rotate, tilt, and animate
the camera.
Now imagine if your
favorite TV show was filmed
using only panning and zooming.
The impact of the scene would
be significantly reduced.
The director just wouldn't
have used their full tool set.
So here's a map.
It's what you've seen many
times before, top down,
projecting a certain region,
at a predetermined zoom level.
Boring.
Now let's take a
look at the same map
and adjust its
rotation and its tilt.
Now it feels like much
more of a real place.
We get a greater sense
of depth, like there's
a bigger world out there.
This map evokes a
much stronger emotion.
For me, it's a
sense of curiosity,
to explore what
else is out there.
When directing the camera for a
house hunting app, for example,
the map can be presented
in a way that shows
more of the surrounding area.
There's a beach out there,
some hills this way,
and a national
park out that way.
Let's go to the next house.
You'll notice that the camera is
animating to the next location.
During this journey,
we're effectively
flying over the area.
The position isn't the
only thing that's changing.
There are subtle changes to
zoom, to rotation, to tilt.
And once again, we get
a strong sense of depth,
and a feeling of exploration.
This is crucial in
house hunting scenarios,
since it's all about location.
Camera projections and
animations are powerful tools,
and you should consider
using them for your tool set.
Be sure to check out the
bearing and tilt methods
on the camera position
builder in your code.
Transitions from one
camera position to another
should be animated,
not snapped to place.
So remember, as a
camera director,
it's important to frame
your shot in order
to evoke the desired emotion.
[MUSIC PLAYING]